[Music]
drops
no it's not one and a half knox
marine sad might be my country paws
it's not a pancake what the
dialect the pancake is what on the other hand
the pancake a is a savory dish
systems chain  and of big bear in your
body shop in
[Music]
Syria and of
which she will
compete in tournefeuille number one
very nice team of
[Music]
wat
a pancake is a dish which is
made with buckwheat flour and
we add to it  with us coarse
Guérande salt and also water and we
can possibly add an egg for
the part we do not refuse to serve
a pancake with
ketchup inside when we know we are
asked by a person but we
consider  that the galette comes there are
certain products that we can add
with and others that are not at all
with our culture and our way of
seeing local products
the galette completes a ham cheese
and there really a very particular taste
yes yes yes
or  i afte the brotherhood was created in
1998 comes in our suit to
allow us to distinguish ourselves
from other brotherhoods with
d a suit which is a report therefore
with the product that we defend our
suit and green color it is a
report  with therefore agriculture the
culture of the bathtub on our sleeves and
we have a reproduction embroidered with a
flower of buckwheat our hat and
common dish revels and we wear gloves
for the
present much higher trials
but that you chain them
we  came because it's true that we
are a group of people
who get along wonderfully because it's
true that he's a guy who had a lot a
lot and who still has a
lot of  importance to the fact of the
setca
[Music]